[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way paulie came up with an idea
actually he came up with it yesterday
and i said you got to vet this out a
little bit
and he said all right we're working on
the slam dunk contest which i said i
don't care about slam dunk content well
this is based off john moran
and paulie goes now imagine this if john
morant had a dunk and we got to judge
the best vote on the best dunk the
entire year
and that's how you that's how you crown
the slam dunk contest winner so john
morant is going to get a million dollars
for that dunk unless somebody has a
better dunk you let everybody vote on it
fan involvement a million dollars and
then we get dunkin donuts to sponsor it
and you could even have the d-u-n-k
and then the i could be somebody jumping
it writes itself damn i've already got
it yeah paul and it could be called the
vince carter memorial dunk in-game dunk
award or something maybe not so wordy
and a picture of vince carter dunking
over frederick vice
as the trophy okay
let's bring in uh adam lefko he covers
the nba tnt inside the nba guest host
also covering the draft as well for
bleacher report let's go let me uh start
with that
let me start with
the
season-long
of the year award
and then yeah i don't like it
all right we'll talk to you later thanks
for joining us
wait wait why don't you like the dunk
contest is actually a dunk in a contest
called a game
because
why are we trying to kill this thing so
fast like we had one bad year where cole
anthony took like 20 minutes to tie his
shoes and suddenly it needs to be
completely imploded and fixed yes i will
say i asked the commissioner why don't
we just give them like a million dollars
and he was like that's not gonna get it
done and i was like he's like people are
worried now about embarrassment uh and
it does stink that we got guys like
anthony edwards that are like i'm never
going to do the dunk contest
but
there has to be a way to incentivize
either through fear or intimidation yeah
but johnny
is not going to do this left code now i
get john moran in the dunk contest
even though he's not going to be in a
contest he just dunked in the game
man this is an entire year
oh my god did you see that is that the
dunk of the year
yeah but we still we already asked that
question damn like that happened last
night they're like dunk of the year like
paulie said that and i started thinking
about uh anthony edwards dunk over that
dude on the raptors and i was like oh
it's pretty competitive house of
highlights does this it's the moment of
the year dunk of the year all that stuff
i'm sorry that i came in raining on your
parade i bet you guys were having a
great morning we were uh yeah i kind of
messed that up yeah but i still don't
like the idea okay i love the idea
i do you like bad ideas that's why you
were going to have me on as yes
that is true
uh chris middleton not playing is a big
deal lefko
i think the celtics are going to the to
the finals okay um
i got to
sit right behind
uh where the media sits for game four
and i'm watching celtics nets and i'm
looking at the size of the celtics and
i'm watching imei udoka and i'm watching
this dude have nonverbal communication
with marcus smart from across the court
they're doing
this and smart's like oh yeah and then
i'm looking at steve nash and he's
looking at his assistance and it was a
complete divide so he's doing hand
signals to marcus smart where steve nash
was not really communicating dan there
was one part in the fourth quarter where
goran draghitch looked back at the bench
and yelled something at steve like i
need to know what we're doing here and
steve nash looked at him blankly and i
love steve mitch and then looked at his
assistants and then turned around and
kind of put his hands up and goran
dragach kind of threw his hands like
i'll figure it out myself
and then i'm watching the celtics bench
dan every free throw eemi udoka has
derek white marcus smart every he it
looked like he had the chess move for
every single play but i'm looking at the
bucks team and i'm going so you don't
have chris middleton and you don't have
pj tucker like you did last year who's
guarding tatum yeah like
yeah drew holiday okay then who's
guarding smart they're missing two of
those huge middle pieces now that that's
all the celtics are are six seven
versatile guys and the bucks now don't
have enough of them but i thought kyrie
and kd are the coaches so why wasn't
gordon dragach looking to kyrie and
saying kai what are we doing down the
stretch here
it felt like kyrie and kd were like
we're going to figure this out on our
own that's why it was so impressive to
watch kd in person on monday night
because it was just him going i'm going
to find a way to get to the basket
but
yeah no it
look imi udoka was the lead assistant
for the nets last year maybe he knew all
the things that they were planning to do
anyway yeah but
the the celtics beat the heck out of the
nets every time they played this year
and imei udoka i really think dan is
going to be up for coach of the year for
the next decade
and
it's a few reasons one the way that i
see him patrol the sideline too his
connection with players is unlike any
coach that i've seen and three he's from
the state of akwa in nigeria which is
where my wife is from and they don't
lose i mean he gets to coach the celtics
she ends up with me both big winners
you feel like a play-in game though for
your wife
there are times where i look over and i
go i am the charlotte hornets and this
is important
early exit but boy are they exciting
potential you got a lot of potential
yeah yeah i just i just need to act on
it we'll be fine um
help me understand what doc rivers said
yesterday i'm i'm going to play a
portion of this but he's defending his
past playoff exits here's doc rivers
well it's easy to use me as an example
but i wish i would tell the whole story
with me all right um my orlando team is
the hc
no one gives me credit for getting up
against the pistons who won the title
that was an apc don't look at that i
want you to go back and look at that
roster
i dare you to go back and look at that
roster and you would say what a hell of
a coaching job
really i mean um the clipper team that
we lost 3-1
chris paul didn't play in the first two
games it was playing on one leg
um and we didn't have home court and
then the last one to me is the one we
blew that's the one i think we blew that
and that was in the bubble
and anything could happen in the bubble
there's no home court game seven would
have been in la
you know um
but it just happens so i would say with
me some of them as we go i got to do
better always always take my own
responsibility uh and then some of it is
circumstances happen
this sounds like an exit interview
sounds sounds like to me dan meme
fatigue
this is a man who has seen the memes oh
this is what doctors does he loses 3-1
he loses 3-0
this is again the same time of the year
where all year last year he was
defending ben simmons and he was saying
he's fine he's our guy and then right
around this time of the year he went i
don't know if he could win a
championship and all of that good stuff
got forgotten it's something about this
time of the year where doc just kind of
lets it go but it's it sounded like he
had had enough i am a top 15 coach of
all time according to that
thing that came out earlier this year
for top 15 coaches top 75 players look
at my resume i'm tired of the memes
yeah but doc is beloved by the media
is he
he got coach of the year for an orlando
team that went 41-41 that didn't even
make the playoffs
i i think he should be
criticized even more than he's been
criticized nobody has lost more 3-1
leads he could lose a 3-0 lead
you know there's there's a common
denominator with all of this we love doc
but the results don't back up him
if he loses in this round
are the lakers on the phone when the
buzzer sounds that they lose to toronto
and then they're going to bring doc
in to coach the lakers
right
what you just did right there was a
master class of radio hosting that you
took one story and then you put the
lakers on it which is like inflates it's
tenfold
i'm gonna put the cowboys in there too
somehow you know what and if they could
use some yankees yes that would be
awesome and tom brady what's tom brady
think of doc rivers blowing 3-1 lead i
don't
i don't know if like how beloved doc is
i also thought it was pretty
disrespectful to hey do turkalu rashard
lewis and dwight howard uh and and that
whole crew yeah the orlando team i mean
when he says look at that roster look at
that roster
okay that was one of the most fun teams
that i remember uh but also like the
coach of the year like you were saying
like we love them they're only 41. we
have this weird fascination with coach
of the year where we love to reward the
coach that took a team from bad to
average instead of a team from good to
great yet we give a most improved player
to john morant like that made no sense
to me at all no offense john you're a
great great dunk dunk of the year you
should win a million dollars according
to paul um but
i
with doc
i don't think doc gets any credit for
the celtics championship really like i
feel like it's oh that was a big three
you're right you know you're right and
so i don't feel like he gets the high
end of praise but i actually think that
he
i think he's only remembered
for this he's only remembered for
blowing these leads and i also want to
say i mean joel b did tear a ligament in
his thumb it's not like it's just a
collapse because of bad coaching
like and beads out there playing with
one hand
yeah i know but guys have you said chris
paul was on one leg chris paul averaged
like 21 points and 10 assists in that
series so he still played well hey we
lost in the bubble but hey in the bubble
okay everybody was in the bubble
see doc's not a clutch client and that's
why i'm thinking mark jackson could be
the coach of the lakers because he's a
clutch client um we're talking to adam
lefko by the way
don't be bitter be better all right
all right that's nice yeah
i just made that up
that sounds like a that's a t-shirt yeah
don't be bitter be better
adam left that's like shaq said to me
one time i was like shaq you know you're
a hater and he goes i'm too great to
hate
and i was like what he was like i'm too
great to hate i'm just great that's what
i say and i was like man i put that on
the t-shirt yeah that's pretty good adam
lefko tnt inside the nba guest host and
uh also covering the draft for bleacher
report
give me
the
draft prospect
not being mentioned as a top 10 pick
that will haunt gm's for years to come
okay dan let me ask you a question these
last few drafts all i ever hear about is
position importance got to get your
quarterbacks got to get your tackles but
there's always a guy
taken in the teens that when we do a
re-draft we go how did this guy fall and
it's always the same position
oh aaron donald goes 11. fletcher cox
goes 14. hello to nada goes like 12 or
13. it's always the defensive tackle
that nobody cares about and then we look
five years and they're dominating the
league
how is jordan davis not being talked
about more how do we talk about a guy
all year and say he is the biggest dude
we've ever seen he's got the fastest 40
he jumps the furthest he's on the
national championship he's dominating
offensive lines but he can only play two
downs
first of all how many downs are there
there's three right so he's playing 66
percent of downs which sounds pretty
good to me but two you're telling me i
just watched vida veya
also taken 14th in his draft dominated
d-line and completely arrest defenses
all year for the bucks i just
it just doesn't make sense to me
sometimes when a dude jumps off as an
athlete he's dominant on the field
everyone says he's a leader in the
locker room but
the nfl is all about passing
really like kyle shanahan's entire
offense is built around the running game
and that's we call him the crown prince
of offensive coordinators i think that
when we look back five years from now
all the teams that passed on jordan
davis will regret it and it will be
obvious all right there's a hot take all
right well uh
we'll record that play that back in five
years
nobody loves defensive tackles nose
tackles like i do no one really no one
danny
danny shelton out of oregon state
oh i loved him i'd come in you know
you'd see these guys and i i would say
to the den and i go god this guy's
unbelievable and it'd be a pac-12 game
i'd be watching late at night you know
and you'd go oh danny shelton what did
he wear number eight something like that
and i went danny shelton's awesome
browns draft him and then you're like
whatever happened to danny shelton i
don't know yeah you know but that's not
on him that's all that he took him so
i'm with you with these defensive
you know we should be looking for the
next aaron donald you don't tell me the
games are one in the trenches
and then completely ignore don't talk to
it like dan you've talked to nfl players
and they're like just watch the trenches
but then like we're over here being like
you need a shutdown corner and i'm like
or you could drop you could draft jeff
akuda like we just saw it like
like i don't know man sometimes it just
seems crazy give me the name that you're
struggling with that you might have to
pronounce covering the nfl i was just
i'm so nervous so we're doing the nfl
draft bleacher report it's going to be
the br app tonight and it's on youtube
me connor rogers mike felder then we're
going to be joined by jason kelsey
richard sherman to give uh analysis uh
tori holt i'm on st brown i went online
it was like 2022 draft pronunciation
guide let me just crank this all out in
one spot and it doesn't exist and so
it's not that there's a guy
all i'm hearing from draft people is
there could be guys taking the first
round that we don't even have until day
three and i haven't even looked at them
yet dan so there's guys that are gonna
come out of nowhere then i'm just gonna
go
look at the
linebacker taken by the rape
that's where you go wow that's uh what
did you think of that pic by carolina
let them pronounce the name
it's a beautiful thing when you realize
the limitations of your own job and that
in the end all i have to do is ask a
question
well when i cover the nba draft i kept
thinking
nicholas skittish veli is going to be
coming up
and i'm thinking
and i think he went five overall so i
i'm thinking already you know the
commissioner comes to the podium and you
know with the uh fourth pick the
portland trailblazers take brandon roy
and i'm thinking all right brandon
talk about it uh billis and everybody
else and i'm going when is nicholas
skittish feeli going to be taken and the
denver nuggets select nicholas skittish
veli and then i i thought i don't even
have to say his name so i
went to billus i go what do you think
what do you think of the pick and then
you go skittish feely he's a really
talented uh you know he's a seven footer
run the f
so you don't have to say the names
exactly the commissioner does and then
your analysts do
man like i come on here and i get these
just beautiful pieces of sage advice
every single time but like just remember
you're john stockton
i know you're john stockton that's your
role you don't have to be carl malone
you're john stockton
you'll like this story so one time uh
when it gets late at night for for tnt
tuesdays uh sometimes we'll record like
the last segment of the show if it's
like everything's done the games are
done and all that stuff and i have notes
that i'll work on all week of like
little gems and stuff that i want to
work in there and one time i forgot my
sheet and they were like hey we're going
to do the f the 50s and i was like oh
let me run back and get it really quick
uh and shaq looks at me and i get up and
he puts his hand on my hand his bear
claw and i'm stuck to the desk and he
goes you don't need it
and i was like no i need because i know
he just wants to shoot it and get done
with it and he goes no you don't need it
and i was like no man like i got like i
wrote down like a lot of stuff i want to
say and he goes
you're adam freaking
you don't need it
and the thing is is i know that he was
just trying to convince me so that we
could just get it done but it hit so
hard that i was like i'm adamant
and
his mind control worked and i just made
stuff up all right well don't screw it
up tonight okay
you know what that's the that's the
advice i need defensive lineman done
contest of the year okay i learned a lot
today this is good you're a play-in game
in regards to your wife
that didn't need to be repeated she's
right in the other room that could have
gone bad
we're keeping it a secret dan keep your
head up you're the guy in wide world of
sports who goes tumbling down
the uh you know over his skis
100 the wide world of sports thrilled a
victory in the agony of defeat and that
guy is like tumbling down the mountain
that's you i'm a human blooper yeah
keep your head up i'll try all right i
love you guys thank you adam that's adam
lefkow tnt inside the nba and uh he'll
be working for bleacher report tonight
hosting the draft take a break our play
of the day is up next here dan patrick
show